c'est dans la région le haut-lieu de
l'économie numérique le labo à orly on
rassemble une impressionnante quantité
de geeks et cette concentration de
compétences et d'appétence pour le
numérique ne peut faire oublier que 13
millions de français
112 mille habitants de l'agglomération
orléanaise enlève de l'exclusion
numérique les outils numériques ça
permet de faire ses démarches au
quotidien payer ses impôts s'inscrire à
pôle emploi a les printemps et c'est
donc c'est vraiment des choses très
important pour le quotidien des gens et
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya plein de gens qui
ne savent pas le faire alors pour aider
six exclus du numérique être prêt en
quand les démarches administratives
pourront plus se faire avec du papier
c'était ma us combattants de toutes les
exclusions qui vient à la rescousse
il y avait un premier enjeu qui était
celui de l'accès qui devient peut-être
enfin qui reste centrale malgré tout la
question de la formation est maintenant
absolument clé et puis derrière il ya un
enjeu de coordination des acteurs parce
que tout le monde se positionne plus ou
moins sur cette thématique mais elle est
très transverses donc il faut se
coordonner pour arriver à quelque chose
d'efficace
et c'est l'opération que le conseil
d'agglomération a initié cet après midi
là dans les locaux du labo avec les
acteurs des services administratifs et
sociaux concernés
l'idée c'est aussi de former tous les
agents dans les centres sociaux les
agents dans les mairies proximité dans
tous les lieux dans les espaces publics
numériques informer aussi tous les
aidants qui vont être en mesure
d'accompagner les gens qui ne seraient
pas équipés effectivement les aidant
ainsi identifier et former auront à
faire face à un public plus varié qu'on
l'imaginé
la fracture numérique concerne en effet
des personnes de toutes générations et
de tous niveaux d'éducation